You know that the FirebaseArray
class uses ChildEventListeners.
And it does that by implementing the
ChildEventListener callback interface.
The point of the FirebaseArray class
is to keep a collection of items
that are in the Firebase database,
in sync with a bunch of matching
database snapshot objects that
are in the fire base array class.
Specifically the snapshots are stored in
an instance variable called m snapshots.
So Firebase array uses these child event
listeners to see when things are added,
removed, changed, or
moved in the Firebase database and
then make the changes in its
own internal array list.
And then it triggers the Firebase
list adapter which makes all
the visual changes.
I was actually messing around with the
Firebase array code a bit earlier and
created a little mini project.
And you can use this mini project to get
practice using some of the child even
listener code.
This is all optional, but if you'd like
to get some practice writing code with
some ChildEventListeners, I'd suggest
taking a deep dive into the code of
the Firebase Array and
Firebase listed after classes.
It'll also make it a bit more clear
about how the internals of these
classes work.
I'll send over my code now and
you can take a look.